imágenes de una cámara de seguridad era
de madrugada en kiev cuando un bombardeo
alcanzó un centro comercial en el
distrito de poder en el noroeste de la
capital ucraniana horas más tarde los
alrededores rodeados de escombros
y se repetía una explosión en el lugar
desde ucrania culpan a rusia de atacar a
civiles
supongo que será interesante mostrarle
al mundo entero que no tenemos ningún
objetivo militar estratégico aquí como
dicen los rusos se fue del fruto rubor
pero rusia asegura que era un arsenal
atacó las coordenadas de la posición de
los lanzacohetes ucranianos fueron
confirmadas por el reconocimiento ruso a
través de varios canales así como la
ubicación de un almacén con municiones
para cohetes también fue descubierto
todo para el período ya doctor aquí en
la escena los cuerpos todavía yacen en
el suelo los familiares buscan a los
suyos
es difícil hablar para mí porque mi hija
solía trabajar aquí y estaba en el
trabajo ayer y eso sucedió ayer por la
noche
mientras el alcalde vitali klitschko
volvió a decretar un toque de queda
el toque de queda en kiev se fortalecerá
nuevamente comenzará hoy a las 8 de la
noche y se prolongará hasta las 7 de la
mañana del 23 de marzo es decir hasta el
miércoles comercios farmacias
gasolineras e instituciones no
funcionarán
las fuerzas rusas han llegado a los
suburbios de la capital pero todavía no
han logrado acceder según la
inteligencia británica están ubicadas a
25 km desde rusia publicaron imágenes de
más refuerzos militares cruzando la
frontera